one year out from the 2024 election and
Joe Biden is losing stunning new polls
and must-win swing States painting a
catastrophic picture for the president
Donald Trump leading President Biden and
five states crucial to winning the White
House Biden only clings to a narrow
advantage in Wisconsin but that's not
all the damage Biden is bleeding
critical support from all aspects of his
Coalition quote voters under 30 favor Mr
Biden by only a single percentage point
his lead among Hispanic voters is down
to single digits and while women still
favored Mr Biden men preferred Mr Trump
by twice as large a margin team Biden is
just brushing it all off saying there's
no cause for concern and pointing out
how Barack Obama was also losing at this
point in his reelection campaign but
speaking of the former president his top
strategist David Axelrod is suggesting
that Biden should drop out the issue is
not uh for him is is not uh political
it's Actuarial and you can see that in
this poll I mean there's just a lot of
concern about the age issue and uh and
that is something that I think he needs
to uh Ponder just do a check and say is
this the right thing uh to do time is
fleeting here and this is probably the
last moment uh for him to do that check
and it's it's it's probably good if he
does Axel Rod is not alone the media is
also seriously worried about Biden's
reelection
prospects these polls are alarming now
yes but still should serve as the wakeup
call that the Biden campaign and the
country needs to understand what the
stakes are this is a wakeup call this is
frightening for not just the Biden White
House not just for Democrats but for
anybody who fears what a return to a
trump presidency would mean in all
cander truth serum this has to be like a
political five alarm fire in the White
House Harold Ford Jr it's great to have
you back around the table and um about
two months ago the Washington Post had a
poll that had Trump over Biden 10 points
and even if you remember the Washington
Post even put in the rep its own
reporting that this is probably an
outlier everyone should just not freak
out but it turns out several polls since
have all shown the same thing and now
the New York Times saying that do you
think Axel Rod is speaking for many
Democrats he's like willing to say out
loud what many Democrats are thinking so
good to be back I'd put in two camps
first there is a belief in the Democrat
Party uh and and and the biggest thing
that unites Democrats is that they don't
want uh Donald Trump as president again
so you now have polling consistent
polling showing Joe Biden not being able
to defeat him uh in key States the
national polling is relevant when you
get that kind of polling and you see
five or six states Arizona you got to
think the Border has something to do
with it there the other States the thing
that I found most interesting is the the
22% African-American support the fact
that Trump was leading in more diver the
more diverse the state was the more
former president Trump was winning the
second thing that alarms me as a part of
this is that the president uh Biden has
named his economic message and economic
plan going forward
bonics and there's one constant American
politics presidential Politics the
economy is always the issue even if
National Security and other cultural
issues are part of it it all comes back
to the economy the Border can come back
to the economy it's National Security
and obviously what we're dealing with in
Israel and Ukraine uh as I listened to
David Axelrod I heard the same thing I I
wonder if he's suggesting that the
president's age and maybe a lack of
comfort with vice president Harris as a
as a backup to the president are those
issues that Democrats are are heavy on
Democrats minds I think if you're one of
the big state Governors thinking about
running and obviously there's somebody
in the race in the primary side but
Democrats you got to think about how do
you how do you stir support in South
Carolina how do you stir support perhaps
in Iowa New Hampshire is a little bit of
an outlier because of the the challenges
and the consternation between the
campaign the Biden campaign and them and
and and Biden choosing to put South
Carolina in front I saw a poll that
showed even black voters in South
Carolina have some some reservation
about President Biden so this is this
indeed is a wakeup call I would
encourage a Democrat to distinguish
between when President Obama was down in
2012 on two fronts one uh we were not in
two Wars uh then and President Biden ran
on having this kind of experience and
two uh the person that was the front run
on the other side and that time it
likely was Mitt Romney I don't know if
it was Mitt Romney but went on to be the
Nomine he probably wasn't the front run
at the time he didn't have some of the
baggage that President Trump and this is
not an indictment on President Trump per
se but he's facing a lot of counts a lot
of legal counts a lot of legal issues so
this is this is not not just a five for
I think the the White House they've got
to think about pushing a reset button
here because what what's happening and
what they're doing uh is not resonating
with part of their base and the most
important part of the democratic base
are black voters one of the things that
the Biden team last week said Jesse is
that the fundamentals of the race are
strong which is a tell that they have a
problem the second thing is what did
President Biden do today in the wake of
this he gave a speech in front of Amtrak
and gave them and talking about $25
billion for Amtrak which does not
address anything that people are
concerned about well like Harold it's
also very good to be back around the
table great to have you here I love how
the media needs their own Poll for a
wakeup call like a big Max $18 and they
need to run a poll to know that Joe's
going to get shalacked I was all in on
the Red Wave so I might need to temper
what I'm going to say about this but
Dana when I see a poll this good I have
a hard time staying away from it and
this poll is good this is Landslide City
this is is 300 electoral votes for Trump
this is Trump might win the popular vote
if he sweeps all these Battleground
States and you know what that means Dana
if you get a win like that it doesn't
necessarily just mean it's a rejection
of bomic it's an endorsement of Maga if
you have a country coming out and voting
this overwhelmingly for Donald Trump
this is Maga country maybe Chicago is
Mega country if these numbers shake out
so you're going to have to then if Trump
wins uproot everything about Biden
nomics you're going to uproot the entire
green New Deal and this is a full
endorsement for the president to lock
down the border the media is going to
have to lie for Joe Biden to win and
they're going to have to lie much more
than they did four years ago the media
is going to have to tell you that having
$5 in your pocket is better than having
$10 they're going to have to tell you
that war is good they're going to have
to tell you the border is secure and
crime is only a red State problem and I
don't think they're going to be able to
put they're Liars but they're not that
good of a liar Dana now blacks Hispanics
and Young Americans looking at me when
you I'm looking at Young
Americans so this is the Biden base it's
collapsed so three years of Joe Biden's
policies it's sunk in Blacks Hispanics
Young Americans it's over you cannot win
an election as a Democrat and tie the
Republic with Hispanics you cannot tie
the Republican with young voters you
cannot have a republican candidate win
more than 20% of the black vote I mean
that just shatters your entire Coalition
and now everybody sees what we saw from
the very beginning this was a corrupt
detached man who's a DC dinosaur that
has no clue what he's doing and now you
can't even afford to buy a house so
Obama world is coming in to try to save
the day and it's not just Axel Rod Eric
Holder said the other day that you know
these judges really shouldn't be
throwing Trump in prison on gag order
violations you're making this guy into a
hero Bezos the second richest man in the
world who wuns the Washington Post
doesn't want to have anything to do with
the second Biden term the CIA is leaking
that they don't want Joe back in the
white house there's a lot of powerful
forces that are aligning to get this guy
out of here and now you're getting these
push Poes from ABC News the New York
Times not looking good Kaye this is also
the poll was before when looks to be
more internal strife within the
Democratic party about President Biden's
strong support for Israel yes and that
will also chip away because you even had
people on his campaign apparently
wanting to write a letter to the
commander-in-chief telling him to back
off of his support of Israel yes young
people do not approve of his approach to
Israel Arab Americans 17 177% approval
rating for President Biden so you're
right this is before all of that if I am
Joe Biden I'm his campaign and I'm
looking at this poll I dug through it
today
would Joe Biden be good for the country
when you add up the very good and
somewhat good guess what total you get
8% 8% think he would be good for the
country and then you look at president
Trump how would he handle issues Vis Joe
Biden who would be better off 20%
advantage on the economy 9% advantage on
National Security 9% advantage on Israel
before you get to Black voters to your
point I never thought I'd read in the
New York Times about Trump's support
among black voters unseen and
presidential politics for a Republican
and modern times that is the kind of
support Trump's getting now big caveat
and star on this you have to
operationalize these numbers that means
in Pennsylvania you have to learn how to
combat 40 days of early voting in Nevada
where he has an 11-point advantage you
have to learn to combat some of the laws
they've codified where Mass mail out
voting is the law of land you have to
bank votes in the way the Democrats do
right now it looks like this is how low
can you go for Joe but you've got to
operationalize this for an GRE
gell just want to say it's great to be
back around Harold uh you said in some
cases Joe is down to single digits and I
think we know what single digit America
is giving him uh why do they why do they
just tell him this is his second term do
you think he'll know but in all honesty
I mean it's not AB it's not Age It's
ability and his actions as predicted if
you wanted a second term from Trump give
the Dems a term in between because for a
you give the country a break from the
media's TDS which really didn't go away
and you let the Democrats drive the car
into the ditch Trump gave Joe a stable
country and Joe set it on fire and this
is what happens when you choose nice
words and no Deeds over good deeds and
mean words Joe was supposed to smooth
out all those frumpled lumps in our
nation's fabric this was a war for the
soul of the nation and what did we get
yeah we got more division we got more
war we got more crime more inflation
more unfettered illegal immigration so
this is why with Trump you need to
always focus on the deeds and live your
life so how do you do that so I had an
epiphany and I wrote it down I had this
Saturday night I was listening to this
critic talk about the opportunity cost
of trump his device of Personality takes
your eye off the ball and that's the
reason we got this Hamas attack which is
interesting and the critic says he
admitted that Trump's policy on the
Middle East was better and safer but it
was his personality that was a problem
so this is The Epiphany Trump's not in
office and they still obsess over him
three years later the opportunity cost
actually grew greater under Joe Biden
which means if you like Trump's policies
but couldn't handle Trump's Behavior you
should probably still vote for Trump
anyway because whether he wins or not
the derangement will persist so you have
a choice Trump Obsession Biden policies
or Trump Obsession and Trump policy and
by the way you could replace Trump with
any Republican because the obsession and
the derangement will just take another
shape or form and if you want real
opportunity costs you think about what
we were obsessed with under Biden we
were fixated on the Ukrainian border we
were fixated on you on identity politics
and racism and meanwhile we were scared
to death because our cities were
crumbling and we were plagued by crime
we got all of that all of that plus
Trump derangement without the Trump
policies think about that meanwhile
Trump's not even president and he's
changing the behavior of Democrats
suddenly they start acting like adults
right they they they realize they can't
fight two Wars they realize that
unfettered illegal immigration and a
border collapse is not going to work for
them right and you can't let felons Run
free so in this weird way Democrats are
starting to act like adults because
they're scared to death of a childish
Trump
you had this Epiphany on a Saturday
night this is what I do now wrote it
down and I wrote it down hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now